I don't know if it's been published here
in Sweden but a couple years before the
world of Ice and Fire
there was the map book the lands of Ice
and Fire have any of you seen that have
been published here it's not actually a
book it's a you know a book like object
it's a box and inside there are these
poster sized maps you know this is how
the novels get delayed with stuff like
this let me let me tell you so my
publisher comes to me and they say we
want to do a book just of the maps we
want to make posters of the maps and you
know we'll pay you a lot of money and
you won't have to do any work because
we'll just take the maps and we'll blow
them up to poster size and issue them
we'll do them in color and they'll be
real nice and we'll get professional map
makers and I say oh that sounds good you
know yes I mean a lot of money and and
you do that and I'll just keep writing
my books and then they say you know I
signed the contract and I get a lot of
money and months pass and then I get a
call and saying you know we took the
maps that were in the books and we blew
them up to poster size a lot of blank
space on them and they don't look very
good could you like fill in some more
rivers and mountains and and towns and
stuff like that so okay so I'm I'm
making up mountains on making up towns
it's harder than you think you know you
gotta kind of make sense of the
geography and the rivers have to flow in
the right direction and and you got a
name everything which is pretty damn
tough you know cuz all the good names
have been used in fantasy here unless
you make up names that are just like
nonsense syllables which you can do of
course a lot of fantasy writers do they
have just horrible names that obviously
been generated on the internet by a
fantasy name generator
I've tried to use those and they're
great if you want everybody named Chris
docile otherwise you find yourself okay
mountains here
there'll be let's see the the misty
mountains noblewomen token use the misty
mountains there'll be the the Rocky
Mountains no no they really are Rocky
Mountain the pointy mountains
that's stupid no and you wind up going
until you finally come up with a good
name for the mountains and filling in
North himself though my maps of those
were pretty detailed already but I did
have to make them even more detailed
because now they're blown up to poster
size but then I have to fill in what
esos and esos there was you know it was
a lot less and you know my map of the
Dothrak I see that was a it was a 8 and
an 11 piece of paper on which I had vies
Dothrak and the rest it's a dog I see so
I had like a blank huh I gotta have an
invent a lot of stuff for that here so
I'm I'm filling that in and on the edge
of the map on the edge of all the maps
that I had growing up to that point was
the city of course where Danny reaches
and has adventures and then she turns
around she's been going in one direction
now she turns around goes back the other
way making it way back to it Westeros
but there is a scene in one of the books
where where's Arizona Doc's house comes
to Danny and he presents her with a huge
tapestry of the world in which the city
Qarth is at the center this of course
implies that there's as much to the east
of Qarth as there is to the west of
Qarth so now my publisher saying you
know people are read about this tapestry
they want to see the rest of the world
here and so now I'm drawing what's on
the other side of course which led to an
interesting day discrepancy because I
had some very early primitive maps about
what's on the other side
cars and I gave those maps to HBO at a
certain point and HBO start issuing maps
which used my which used those maps but
when I was doing the map book I looked
at those maps and US doesn't work I
don't like this I don't like the way as
well I completely threw those out and I
redesigned everything east of Koroth
into something that it I liked a lot
better so the HBO the Game of Thrones
world is significantly different from
dice and fire world and it's even if
it's basic geography because of that
change but then you know I had like
pages east of Qarth so I filled it in
and with rivers and mountains and
valleys and dead cities and live cities
and you know making as much east of
garthe's was west of Qarth so we could
have maps of it and I ran out of names
you know at the end here I was making
tributes I would you know I put in
Carcosa which I figured nobody would get
because it's a really obscure reference
I didn't know true detective was going
to pick up the [ __ ] thing and I put
up qaddafi
by the great way so indecently
Lovecraftian references and all that bit
little tipper to have to HP Lovecraft's
so i put all that in the day you know
the story was never going to go there I
figure that it's just a map we'll put in
a little obscure thing some of the real
hardcore fans will get a kick out of it
and it's fine so the map book comes out
and I've done all this time inventing
cities and mountains and filling in maps
and I think I'm never gonna have to
worry about it
well here comes the world of Ice and
Fire and here comes the notes well what
about yay T we need an article but et
what are you gonna say about the Joker
sigh you better tell us something about
that so now I'm writing entire articles
on the history of these places that I
kind of had to invent in order to have
something on the map because I said that
was breaking I had cars in the middle
what you know once I get into it was fun
you know I'm inventing you know I mean I
could probably go off and write the
story is set in the et with all of the
the various colored emperors and I'm
inventing and you know great emperors
and weird emperors and stuff like that
and the history of Lang and all of that
so that was cool that's another little
thing I stole from Wellcraft
you know when you when you steal from
one previous writer that's plagiarism
but when you steal from many of them
it's research so you very much